Turkish tea drinking is a bit different than the customs we know from England at 4:30,...
...or the elaborate ritual of the tea ceremony in Japan.
It is less complicated and very straightforward, kind of like the Turks themselves.
Get your glass poured, you plunk in one or two sugars according to your taste,...
Take your spoon, stir it. Make a lot of noise with that spoon, a lot of noise.
Hold it by the edge because it's very, very hot.
Sip very slowly...
...because it's hot and also because you're going to have to drink several of these glasses.
Just like potato chips, you just can't have one,...
...for etiquette requires that at least three be served to you.
So, that means you're going to be drinking a lot of tea in Turkey, at all hours of the day.
So, as I said, in my eyes, this little glass of tea is the symbol of all of Turkey.
Turkish tea is ruby red.
Not black or green, but red.
Red is the spirit of patriotic blood flowing in the heart of every Turk.
Red is their flag they wave with great pride.
Red is the rich wool of the colorful carpets they weave.
Red is the dancing tulips of their spring time meadows.
The form of those tulips is reflected in the very shape of the tea glass itself.